Bộ ngoại giao Mỹ hơn 6 niềm thiệt thực của giòn sinh của tế đã bị thương hồi trong lúc mạnh hiện không trai mấy lâm
Năm trong khun hồ chính sách tăng cường kiểm soát nhất cơ.
Quảng bộ nghiên triển ở bên quan đến càng vi vị phản pháp lật như hàng hôn chọn cắt
Hãy like, say, chúng tình chẳng sẽ dầu.
Đáng chú ý lật từ 2,5% trăm đến 3 trong thiệt tựng bị huy,
giòn cáu bộ có liên quan đến các hạt động khu bố,
giòn chứ có thông tin gió sang, với việc những sinh viên này có bị kết đảnh hay không?
Rồi chung Mỹ cho rằng các biển pháp mạnh tay nhằm ngăn chẳng quyết cơ đây soát đến cú già
Đông thời gian đe cạnh vì việc phản pháp lật trong cộng đồng do học sinh
Quuy định này cũng phản nánh định hưởng chính sách nhập cơ cướng sát hơn
Quà chính quyền tổng thống đồ nân trăm, bộn đang gây nhiều trình lận trong xáu Mỹ
Theo thông tin từ bộ ngoại xong Mỹ chia sẻ với Fox News,
những sinh viên bị thương hồi khi thực vì hàng vi hành vinh hồn đang phải đối mạc về việc bị bác sử hộn bị bộ tội.